[Music]
English lessons simple past versus the
present perfect no one seems to
understand when to use one or the other
the simple past I went I saw I use when
I talk about a specific moment in the
past I saw Captain Marvel last Saturday
something that is over the present
perfect I have been I have seen
something that happened in the past yes
but I don't specify the moment I have
been to New York five times when it's
not important
my experience is more important okay
there is no defined time of course as
always we have some exceptions
he sure is talking about 2019 I can
still use the present perfect because
just house 19 is going on what have you
done in 2019 what have you seen in 2019
to sum it all up when I use the simple
past I'm talking about a specific moment
in the past something that is finished
and if I use the present perfect I'm
talking about the past but the moment is
not defined it's not important I hope
this will help you speak English a
little bit more fluently see you next
time
[Music]